so after three years of video reviewing
a common question I get asked by a lot
of you guys goes along the lines of this
gig accused sexy charismatic stallion
how on earth do you go about making your
abuse and do you have any advice for any
new anime reviewers now while I do try
to be helpful when I can
it does get taxed and repeating the same
things over and over again so instead of
repeating the same advice today on the
enemy zone I'm gonna be making a video
about making videos now I realize not
all my viewers are interested in being
reveals or ranters but I still try to
make this as interesting as possible and
maybe give you some insight into what
happens behind the scenes of these
reviews okay so my first point may be an
obvious point but at the same time it is
one of the most important things on
making any kind of video on YouTube try
to be interesting whatever video you're
making if you aren't interesting that no
one's gonna watch your stuff obvious
fact it helps if you're actually
interested and passionate about the
stuff you're talking about and love just
some guy sounds like they're reading out
loud from a dictionary so really don't
start making videos to get to
internet-famous or for potential
partnership because i'm telling you
right now the biggest satisfaction I get
from making this stuff is just getting
your opinion out there and seeing the
views comments and ratings from
different people that's basically it
you're gonna be spending a lot of time
making these videos and if you're not
enjoying it then this will radiate to
the viewer which is never a good thing I
recommend writing out a script or at
least taking notes on a thing you're
talking about because unless you have
the memory of Rain Man or just really
good at improvising you're gonna miss
some stuff completely forget what you're
talking about and just stare blankly at
the camera like a dunce or at least miss
some important points that you wanted to
talk about of course there are many ways
to make a video review interesting but
that has more to do with the next step
finding your own style do you want to be
a completely professional reviewer
objectively deconstructing every little
component of the show do you want to be
a showing of the mug on the internet and
mastering the art of instantly
teleporting to different positions on
screen do you want to be an entertainer
taking the piss out of a show for shits
and giggles or a mix of something in
between whatever you do you have to try
and find your own style that you're
comfortable with and stick with it this
may have to start with you trying to
imitate your favorite internet person
and get accused of being a ripoff but
keep doing it anyway eventually you'll
find your own style some people still
call me a Yahtzee report and while I do
admit that I drew a lot of inspiration
from him in the beginning I'd like to
think that I'm a lot more honest than
here since I haven't actually watched
him in years but the important thing is
that I'm completely comfortable in my
own style now which is totally not
copied from Charlie Brooker Frankie boy
eh Jimmy Carmichael McIntyre David
Mitchell the nostalgia critic the
GAMEOVER thinker anyway sound quality a
big thing that gets overlooked in video
reviews is the sound quality which in my
opinion is actually more important than
your video quality even if your video
quality Spock was more than vampires and
Twilight's people will still be watching
to listen to your voice in opinion and I
was gonna want to watch your stuff when
he saw like a monotone alien talking
through a microphone that was made in
the 16th century like this for example
[Music]
absolute [ __ ] you don't even need to
have the best microphone in the world to
have good sound quality audacity is a
free recording software that can help
you in removing background noises and of
course edit your sound get rid of all
the ins and R's that break up the flow
of the video and make you sound like a
stuttering [ __ ] keeps the pacing up
the chains of your attention and it
might actually trick people into
thinking that you know what you're
really talking about that's an a British
accent of course that's what you should
sound like well you need to hone your
own reviewing and ranting voice which is
not what you will sound like a normal
conversation I don't sound like this in
normal conversation if I did my friends
would probably think I was an annoying
stuck-up prick but on the internet an
engaging voice will help make your
opinions more interesting to listen to
but on the Internet imagine that you're
talking to potentially hundreds or even
thousands of people so you don't want to
step on this big stage in front of a
massive crowd of people and then start
whispering to the nearest pausing
butterfly what to recommend is searching
the internet for your favorite review of
rants or public speaker and paying close
attention to what they sound like and
how they speak what is it about the way
they emphasize their lines that make
them more interesting to listen to than
say random internet kids or my favorite
naruto chapter and try to do the same
thing with your own voice focus in this
verse and then focus on making your
videos look pretty next step include
opinions one big mistake I see from a
lot of video reviews is they spent
approximately six and a half hours
explaining the plot and the characters
which any viewer could check in about a
minute on a and n and then they
proceeded to spend a single sentence
explaining their opinions on the show
remember you are a reviewer not a
walking encyclopedia unless you have a
way of making it funny or entertaining
keep the plot and character descriptions
short brief and spend more time on what
you thought about the show what was good
about it what wasn't good about it and
more importantly what are the things
about the show that stood out
just remember not everyone will have the
same opinion as you and that's fine it's
impossible to come from a completely
unbiased objective viewpoint without
making a complete snoozefest just make
sure that whatever opinions you do
include you have to have some proof to
emphasize the point you're making
otherwise you just sound like a biased
fanboy which was slash of credibility if
you're gonna bash a show make sure you
clearly outline why you're bashing it's
and vice versa when you're praising it
try to look at it from every angle even
if it wasn't for you because chances are
it might be suitable for someone else a
good reviewer can successfully portray
why they personally like the series but
a great reviewer would be able to give
an idea to the audience of whether they
would like it or not regardless of
whether the reviewer did length
unfortunately this is the Internet where
everyone has the attention span of about
0.3 of a second so you don't want to
make your reviews too long yes I know
there are some series that you just need
to spend more time on but in general try
to keep it short snappy to the point and
don't ramble too long on summary
relevant points you can do that in a
separate discussion video if you really
want to personally I think the best
length for a review is between 6 and 10
minutes and lastly stick with it you're
not going to become famous overnight and
good videos take a lot of work for my
first video I literally got around 20
views in the first week and I was [ __ ]
ecstatic when I got my first hundred
subs after months back when the YouTube
anime community was still a baby
compared to now and to give you a
milestone on how long I work on these
videos for for every minute of a review
I make is about an extra hour of
recording and editing so a nine minute
video will take me around nine hours to
make and button cleaning time for
scripting or getting clips but I kept
making videos longer less if you want to
get some quick and easy views good ways
of getting initial views is to make
video responses where people who
wouldn't normally get to see yourself
get a chance to check you out and see
what you're really about heck I feature
a video response at the end of every
rant for this exact reason just make
sure if you do make a video response you
actually have your own points or build
up from the points of the original video
and aren't just like was a great video I
totally agree with all the points you
had in addition you can try by starting
with talking about more popular topics
sending it around on forums and if your
stuff is good
it will get noticed eventually what
worse comes worse I always try to give
extra exposure to any reviews I think my
fan base would be interested in such as
holding reviews to cerb jeans history
man's EP anime otaku or whom you
find in the description below cough
cough I think I said four general points
though but for anyone who wants more
specific details about making reviews
I've made a blog post but you can again
find in the description below where I go
a little deeper and talk about things
like dodging copyright claims on YouTube
structuring your review equipments and
other stuff so if you're really
interested in making reviews I recommend
checking out my post for that anyway
that's it for me now though so I'm sorry
I don't have a new review or rant up but
with me almost graduating for university
and finals coming up spared some has
been very limited for me and this video
was a lot less work than my usual
reviews so until I'm free of all this
I'll see you all next